[Music]
microsoft have been busy defending the
xbox one after getting in a little bit
of trouble from the natural resources
defense council a senior scientist at
the council called the xbox one's
instance on feature which allows the
console to boot up more quickly and
allows it to download updates in the
background quote poorly designed
claiming its energy usage is wasteful
Microsoft seems to have agreed claiming
users of course for this feature since
the xbox 360 era the company has said
the big instant-on and automatic update
options save gamers a lot of time
although they have added that the
company is committed to sustainability
the xbox one does feature and energy
saving mode where the console won't turn
on instantly or download updates in the
background Microsoft have said that in
the coming months they are going to
provide this energy consumption choice
to users when they set up their console
for the first time on the flip side the
same report acknowledged a recent change
in the ps4 power consumption in its rest
mode which switched off the USB ports if
the controllers were completely charged
let me know down in the comments if
you're a fan of energy saving or
instant-on features will keep you
updated on all the latest so stay tuned
to gamespot
[Music]